à son balcon cet homme constate
l'ampleur des dégâts il est miraculé son
immeuble vient d'être touché par une
frappe russe kiev la capitale
ukrainienne s'est à nouveau réveillée
sous les bombes
il y avait du bruit quelque chose voler
dans le ciel au dessus de nous
je suis venu à la fenêtre mais je n'ai
rien vu
après l'explosion je me suis estimé
chanceux parce que je voyais toutes les
fenêtres se briser
de tous les côtés
heureusement il n'ya pas eu de victime
pas de blessés ici mais les autorités
ukrainiennes dénombre déjà plus de 130
morts et 310 blessés dans tout le pays
pour majorité des civils la russie
continue d'affirmer qu'elle ne vise que
des sites militaires ils disent que les
zones civiles ne sont pas une cible mais
c'est encore un de leurs mensonges en
réalité ils ne font aucune distinction
entre les zones dans lesquelles ils
opèrent le président a également annoncé
la conscription général en clair tous
les hommes de 18 à 60 ans doivent rester
dans le pays car les combats
s'intensifient sur la route de kiev les
russes gagnent du terrain il affronte en
ce moment les soldats ukrainien à yvan
qui fait diminuer respectivement 1 80 et
45 kilomètres au nord de kiev à yvan
kiffe ce pont n'a pas résisté aux
assauts la russie qui tentent également
de prendre le contrôle de l'aéroport de
ce tome elle après l'avoir attaqué hier
ailleurs en ukraine les troupes de
vladimir poutine contrôler plusieurs
zones du pays au nord la centrale de
tchernobyl au sud le nord de la crimée
et à l'est des régions proches de
kharkiv et de louhansk comme celle de
soumis
malheureusement les zones peuplées de la
région de soumis sont assiégées
des véhicules militaires de la région se
dirige vers kiev beaucoup de matériel
sont passés par là et se dirige
directement vers l'ouest
face à la guerre les ukrainiens tentent
de se protéger en dehors des abris ils
se réunissent dans les stations de métro
comme ici à kharkiv
cent mille personnes auraient déjà fui
le pays selon l'onu